was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja die wir hoffen
natürlich geht es gut ich habe heute mal
wieder meine freunde machen dabei weil
wir haben das letzten weil wir haben den
letzten tag schon zusammen gedreht da
ist nämlich kannst du dich noch erinnern
er da ging es um eure lieblings amazon
punkte bzw
produkte die euch sehr gut gefallen
haben die irgendwann mal bestellt hat
und wo man sagen kann 'die musste alex
auch mal testen und holt ein zeit fällt
dabei ja aber das lag an uns wird da war
ein bisschen dumm
ich habe nämlich echt ein paar videos
von leuten bekommen die haben das nur
nachgestellt mit dieser diese
aufblasbaren einer luftmatratze oder
reis war das geht wohl wenn es ich weiß
nicht was wir daraus machen auf jeden
fall haben wir heute eine besonderheit
ich habe in die sache nicht selber
ausgesucht also ich weiß selber noch
nicht was wir dort gleich vorfinden
werden es handelt sich insgesamt um fünf
produkte und das wurde ausgesucht von
einem mitarbeiter von unserer social
media agentur deswegen das macht das
ganze eigentlich noch mal ein bisschen
interessanter
ich würde sagen wir da man nicht lange
gefallen direkt waren wenn ihr ein
produkt habt was wir hier unbedingt mal
testen sollen dann könnt ihr mir das
super ins land schicken da hat sich alex
w wie auch sonst ne und metzger und
zeigt
eine schöne neue haare ich habe eine
neue frisur die s9 die fusion ist danke
das ist das erste produkt paket wie auch
normal pakete haben wir denn wir haben
zum 31 kommt jetzt gleich das alles
bisschen dunkler mal was kommt jetzt
vielleicht war nicht frau merkel also
für mich sieht das so aus wie eine
schwere aber halt also es ist ja
wahrscheinlich schon normale schirme mit
der dort papier stein kannst aber hier
haben wir noch so eine pizza aufsatz
doch ich habe lohne
es ist nicht wahrscheinlich gegen das
dazu dass du halt nicht so dass du nicht
immer anheben musste ich mein weil die
pilze mit einer schere schneidet das ist
ein bisschen kompliziert kann ja keine
fixe einher deutschland ein also bis
jetzt kann ich noch nicht sagen ob das
wirklich gut ist wir müssen es
ausprobieren das machen wir so marie
zeigt uns jetzt mal wie das geht
hast du denn die pizzeria da ja los
jetzt jetzt jetzt guck mal ob das was da
der sinn ist etwas steht dann hier auf
dem tod
hier ist das produkt guckt so geht das
ja an sich hat es echt nicht so viel
sinn
stoppt das ist hier nicht komplett
durchschneidet du musst ja immer jetzt
stückweise schneiden weil dabei ja was
macht das hier dient ja bloß als maßstab
du hast das jetzt schon gut gemacht sagt
1 jetzt gehen wir mit der ganzen sache
rum und schneiden hier einmal reinen ja
an sich hast du irgendwie auch ein
bisschen weil ich aber jetzt haben wir
das erste stück braucht jetzt können wir
das zweite ungefähr wieder also ungefähr
wieder nach diesem maßstab schneiden
haben dann das nächste stück raus so
soll ich ja der sinn dahinter sein oder
das kann mal sehr denn so
perfektionistisch dass man die pizza
genau in gleichgroße stücke geschnitten
haben das weiß ich auch nicht es kann
natürlich sein dass die pilze ein
bisschen zu klein dafür ist trotzdem
würde ich sagen ein ganz normaler
pizzaschneider diese wollen ist einmal
das beste und das ist ein bisschen und
also von mir gibt es hier für maximal
vier von zehn punkte also ohne aufsatz
ist es viel leichter oder dann geht das
auch ziemlich schnell so dass magst du
und ich zeig dir mal wie man das macht
[Musik]
da sind mehrere sachen drin
und wie viel sie mental kaputt
entschuldigung ich habe in ordnung klein
aus setzt euch mal ein bisschen neben
der spur
aber wir haben das ding hast du mir auch
geschenkt hat liegt die eu besteht schon
mal drauf made in china das ist kein
gutes zeichen weil das ist so ein
produkt ich weiß wie wir euch daran
erinnert ich habe ja mal diese videos
gemacht ich teste amazon produkte die
ich nie bestellt habe und das war auch
alles so exotische machen
wir haben jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal
raus bekommen das ist hier ein
luftbefeuchter nimmer rieso dann steckt
man den hier einstellt immer dahin auch
aber das ist ja das macht ja gar kein
licht steht ja das nicht machen
das lustige ist wundert euch über den
hintergrund das unaufgeräumte ich hab so
was ähnliches hier in etwas größer von
der kammer auch so ätherische öle reihen
füllen das habe ich dann auch mal
gemacht und zwar street
unser super frame marias doch geschafft
erklärt doch mal was gemacht ich habe so
lange gedrückt gehalten und dann ändert
dass auch die farben rosa aus jetzt
müsst ihr das wieder angehen und jetzt
wieder haben angehen ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich habe keinen plan hat
das gekostet hat werde ich euch hier auf
jeden fall mal einen dann also an sich
ist ganz cool aber ist jetzt auch nichts
weltbewegendes ne also familien für das
produkt acht von zehn sternen
es wirkt alles
im semi professionell das lustige ist
wir haben ja so eine kleine beschreibung
dabei und da steht einfach drin
if you have any questions please contact
at gmail.com cm kommen also die haben
nicht mal seine business male ich habe
nämlich marie so was ähnliches mal
geschenkt ein bisschen größer
das ist irgendwie jetzt habe ich hier in
eheringe ja okay wir lassen einfach mal
laufen sieht ja ganz schön aus und
machen weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
das ist wieder mein vater kommt man
solche droht der finger von alex
erfindung ist macht das nie was nachher
steht da nein das ist jetzt unser
ehering
okay das ist tatsächlich schon das
nächste produkt das ist auf jeden fall
das kleinste was wir jemals hatten und
zwar steht schon drauf was es ist es ist
ein einkaufswagen löser zweierpack davon
braucht ich muss ehrlich sagen es ist ja
aktuell in vielen supermärkten so die
regel dass man nur mit einkaufswagen
rein darf weswegen dieses ding
wahrscheinlich absoluter top server ist
aktuell die auch sich schon davor stand
nicht dass ich musste auch schon so auf
den supermarkt eingehen und dann kommst
du halt nicht rein weil du keinen euro
dabei ist oder nicht so einem chip
dann musst du erst vornherein ist ein
bäcker oder so muss fragen ob die
irgendwann schuld gibt
deswegen muss ich sagen an sich was
schämen und steht allerdings noch aus
wieso das wird schon klappen ich muss
gleich einkaufen ein kurzes video
kümmern 63 und tiefs wieder raus und du
kannst es sogar anderen schlüssel grund
machen und das hier
das finde ich ultra du hast da sie erst
zum reinstecken
ja ist ja ok aber hier kannst du es
anderen schlüssel gutmachen hier muss
ich sagen das finde ich eine ultra ultra
gute idee weil man verliert ihr auf
diese chips deswegen gibt es formiert
für dieses produkt direkt zehn von zehn
punkte einer geist produkt hatte wenn es
funktioniert
das würde das wäre mega vorhabens nicht
funktionieren da habe ich jetzt wieder
dran das ist richtig weiß was es aber
ich weiß nicht was das mit unserer musik
sei das was so einen luftschlag
aber das ist wahrscheinlich wieder mit
mehr irgendwas oder also wir haben hier
einen bus corp der hat so ganz spezielle
muster also wird sind einzel reist man
gern 25 verschiedene kleine düsen wir
jemals nochmal aus zwölf einzeln düsen
bestehen also kunden spiegelte auch noch
dabei
es geht also ich würde sagen wir müssen
das ja mal testen soll ich das jetzt
einmal die büsche schrauben
wir gucken machen ich glaube das ist
halt so ein massage ding oder vielleicht
leuchtet ihr auch weil ich kann mich
daran erinnern ich hatte so was schon
mal ruhig und da hat der duschkopf
plötzlich angefangen zu leuchten und
wird auch in seiner zuletzt so was läuft
an und lass dir war auch das besser
machen hatte sich alles besser und hatte
du schnell bist für mich auch dass auch
also wenn der dusche richtig hart ist
dann ist das echt ok
wow ich muss wirklich sagen ich muss das
eigentlich musste gleich mal testen wenn
ich wiederkomme von der arbeit
weißt du warum der besser ist weil man
nicht gut damit leichter ausgewaschen
bekommt als frau damit so ein bisschen
bleibt immer vorläufig shampoo in haar
so leute und ich hoffe wir können das
jetzt noch mal sehen wie viele
verschiedene düsen das ding hat also
auch hier muss ich sagen noch kein fazit
das ewig gleich aber erst ein bisschen
sollte ich lass das jetzt mal hier läge
hat dieser strahl der das ganze war hier
unter wasser eingesetzt wird ist ein
bisschen zu stark
also für mich ist ja du streiks wäre das
ganze bad unter wasser bestimmt der du
strahlst letztes paket ist da
klingelingeling neulich mal trat schon
fahren da kann der post wurden hat das
wird das erinnert mich ein ziemlich
großer verspätung dass carmen sollte
einen schon vor drei tagen hier sein
also ich muss sagen garten heute kein
großes paket dabei
ich weiß es nicht zu bruch wie ich habe
die sachen nicht bestellt im osten
schien ihren das aber ein bisschen leid
doch das ist sondern eine black neue in
klein warst schon sei ja massage weil
ist das ja das ist so eine black falcon
klein und du kannst mich dass hier ein
bisschen fester marie drücken sich
einmal richtig auch so nacken wo ja das
geht dann muss ich das auch nur gegeben
und dann machst du denn mal und danach
vollständig uns noch einmal wieder das
geld machen wie zum beispiel so dass man
speziell in heimen wurden diese unfähig
klapproth war das ist voll und mit der
lampe also ich muss sagen ich fand es am
besten als du das bei mir gemacht hast
so ist das irgendwie merkt davon ist
nicht so viel also ich muss sagen der
massage ball ist irgendwie jetzt nicht
so nicht so das gelbe vom ei trotzdem
waren geile sachen dabei dürfte das
gefallen lassen da nach oben da aber
hier den kanal folgen uns gemeinsam und
schickt uns weiter produkte wir sehen
uns am sonntag wieder gibt's neues video
zu i